you are from you're from Wales is I'm
from Wales yes this little small country
attached to England yeah yeah you know
I've I've traveled many places I love to
travel to new countries yeah
why would I visit Wales make your pitch
for Wales oh well I there's two great
adverts I've done for the tourist board
you know you do a few advertisements
fool yes Victoria yeah it's crap for
visit Wales yeah yeah it was about the
the coast of Wales which is absolutely
beautiful sure and the other one is
about the historical stories and
Snowdonia are mountain peaks and stuff
like very nice it's a beautiful
beautiful place the people are very warm
very welcoming we speak a very different
language what most of us do I don't I'm
struggling with English yeah you know
it's interesting there's a town in Wales
with I think it holds the world's record
for the longest name in the world I'm
gonna put it up this is a real name of a
town I'm not making this up this is a
real name of a town in Wales how would
you even say that
would you like to go first no no no I
yeah it goes sand virus Queen gilko Gary
Quinn trouble planta silly oh go go go
oh my what is it no you just awaken the
elf what does that mean well the version
I know is st. Mary's Church in a hollow
by the white hazel trees near the rapid
whirlpool by the red cave of the cross
of st. Cecilia can you imagine having to
write that on a return address that
would just what about I feel if you're
on the you you're following the
direction to go damn it do they go past
the wrong world you know what I also
love too is of course I don't know if it
must be a Welsh thing so many actors and
I'm including you as well but you know
Sir Richard Burton and these people that
came from from from Wales with these
these amazing voices you have a terrific
voice it must be something in the water
there or the beer yeah
I don't know I mean I have you putting
me in any close category two people that
Richard Burton and Anthony Hopkins I'm
feel very honored but they are they do
sound incredible and I love listening to
them so recite anything actually yeah
the yellow pages yeah exactly
no I I think it would be I've despised
my own voice but I just sure your voice
I think you have that that same kind of
timbre I think it's a real gift well
thank you yeah I'm bitter
you